hi in this tutorial I'll be going over
how to do web scraping using node I was
kind of inspired by this article I read
client-side web scraping with JavaScript
using jQuery and regex and I wanted to
continue this to kind of make it even
better so instead of using client-side
web scraping I decide to use node
because so I don't have to deal with the
cross origin issues when you're using
node you can basically get information
from anywhere and it's not gonna give
you ears in this article what she does
if she gets actually information from
the free Koch camp website and finds the
number of challenges completed so what I
thought would be interesting is if we
can combine that with web scraping on a
different freaking website on the freako
camp forum there's forums dot freako
camped out org slash users and it's
basically like a leaderboard it's gonna
rank the users by how many hearts that
they received so I thought I'd be
interesting to compare how many hearts
that they received compared to how many
challenges they've passed on free code
camp just to see if there's any
correlation between number of challenges
and how far they've gotten into the free
code camp curriculum with the number of
likes that they've received on the free
code camp forum now you don't
necessarily have to even be on free code
camp and in the curriculum to be on the
forum so there may not be any
correlation but I wanted to use some web
scraping to find out the first thing
we're gonna do is going and go into
sublime text here and I'm going to just
require some dependency so we're gonna
do Const our P equals require and the
first thing is going to be called
request promise and this is going to
make it easier to make Ajax requests
from other websites so we're going to
also have to do MPM install riku request
promise
okay well that's installing I'm gonna do
another line here Const cheerio equals
require it's gonna be called cheerio
material makes it so you can use syntax
similar to jQuery from within node so
that's another thing they'll be easier
to navigate the Dom and different things
like that when we're doing the web
scraping and let's get that installed
NPM install cheerio and then the last
thing is Const table now this next one
is just supposed to make it easier to
format our information for this project
we're not going to create a web browser
or anything it's just going to display
the content the results right in the
console
so this CLI - table is gonna make it
easier to do that so I'll do MPM install
CLI - table and then we'll just let that
install okay so we're going to need to
set some variables one of them is going
to be the let users we're just gonna
have to have an empty array of the users
here so let's start our our first web
scrape here so first we're gonna have to
set our options this is something for
the request promise I'm going to set the
options the first thing is going to be
the the URL we're going to get the data
from now we still to figure that out so
if we go over here to this list we have
to figure out how to get all this
information now now here's one of the
problems a lot of websites render all
the render the page with the JavaScript
so like if I go over here into view page
source and I search for let's say I'll
just search for Quincy because that was
one of the people on there
you can see it doesn't find that name
anywhere even though we can see the name
Quincy right here it's not on the source
it's because after the page loads it
renders all this in JavaScript now one
problem is with you when doing Ajax
requests or requests to other websites
is that it's not going to load all the
JavaScript so we can't just load up this
page from nodejs and expect to see all
this content because it's not going to
load up all the JavaScript so what we're
going to do is try to find if there's an
API that's getting all this information
so I'm going to do a command option J or
I guess we didn't need to do J by just
trying to open up this developer tools
here and I'm going to go to the network
tab now I'm going to refresh this one
more time and it's gonna you can see all
the different calls that it's making to
get the information on the page it's
good it's loading all these different
things so let's go up to the top here
and I'm trying to figure out if there's
a what if there's a list of users okay
if I go to this directory items 1 you
can see the whole list rep the items and
then then it has a few other things if I
click the down arrow oh you can see this
look this is the list of users see that
likes receive it start with 8850 134 and
you can see over here
8850 134 and if we scroll over here well
let me just drop one of these downs
you'll see user and we can actually get
the user names here
so what we're actually going to do is
use the request to get this information
from the API and then you can see the
user name I'm just gonna copy this user
name really quick if we go over to free
code camp org and then I put the user
name on the end you'll see that we'll
get the free code camp profile for that
user the user on the form doesn't
necessarily have to use the same user
name as the
user on the free coconut org website but
in many cases they do that use the same
user so we can use that username to find
the number of challenges passed so to
find out the number of challenges passed
we're gonna actually have to count up
every item on this list here but we'll
get to that in a second
right now we just need to get this link
here so I'm going to let see copy copy
the link address so now I'll go over
here and for URL I'll put this in some
quotes and maybe I will zoom out a
little bit here so we can see the whole
link here and then I'm going to put JSON
to true that means the result is going
to parse the JSON for us and make it a
little easier to deal with the data so
now we're gonna do RP and then pass in
the options or RP was this request
promise that's going to do a Ajax
request and return a promise since it's
returning a promise we can do a dot then
so once the promise is resolved that
means once it's able to get the
information from that website then it's
going to do something so let me pop this
down to the next line and then we're
gonna try to figure out what it's going
to do it's going to give us some
information and I'm gonna put all the
information in this just a variable
called data and now let's we're gonna
make this arrow function here okay let's
set up some variables we have let
promises equal let user data equal so
we're also going to make it an array of
the user data now we're going to for
that user of data directory items and so
it's getting this directory items right
from this data here if you look at this
page over here
you can see that the top level of this
results is directory items so we have to
get into that and I'm going to do user
data dot push when I push onto that
array which is going to be the the data
from the user basically so the name is
user dot user dot user name and I
figured out what this is going to be the
user dot user that username just because
you can see first it has to if you look
in this data here we first we get the
user dot username right there
so also I'm going to set the likes
received to user dot likes received and
now let's see what I'm going to just add
a semicolon that's all we're gonna do
for that well in this for loop and we've
pushed all the data onto there oh and
now that I'm putting it in here I just
realized that I tried a few different
things and I don't actually need this
array of promises when I was figuring
out this code at first I tried something
with this but actually I don't need this
anymore so I'm gonna take that out now
I'm just gonna go down here there was a
time where I was going to try to call a
promise for for each user but then I
decided to go about it a different way
now just for the the purpose of my log
so you can tell what's happening I'm
gonna log something and instead of doing
console that log I'm gonna do process
dot STD out dot right and then just put
loading one thing this does compare the
console that log is it doesn't add a new
line at the end so you can put
everything on the same line so now we're
going to call another function here
which I'm going to create in just a
second which is just get challenges
complete it and push to user array it's
a long for you function name but
just describe what's happening so now
the next function we're about to call is
going to do that it's going to get all
the challenges completed and then push
it to the users array or the users array
is right up here so what I'm going to do
here is add some semicolons and then I'm
gonna do a dot catch so let's see that
catch is just to catch any errors that
happen from this Ajax call and I'm going
to yeah just do this little function
here and we're just going to console dot
log the error if there's an error now
I'm going to create that function I'm
actually just gonna copy this so I don't
have to type that again so I'm going to
put function and I'm gonna have the user
data pass 10 still and let's define that
function this is where it's gonna go
through each user and make another
request for each user on the list
there's a few ways to do this but I want
each request to be in order so that the
the hearts will be in order like this so
I just want to make sure that the data
the data is in the order that it is on
here so when you make a different
request is asynchronous so you don't
know which resolves going to come back
first so the way I figured that out to
do well let me just show you how I'm
gonna do it to get the everything in
order you may be able to find a better
way to do this but this is just one of
the first things I came up with I'm
going to do var I equals 0 when I set
this is basically a counter variable and
then I'm gonna create a function called
next so we're actually gonna keep
calling this function it's gonna be used
some recursion here so if I is less than
user data that length
if we haven't gotten to the end of the
list we're gonna do this I'm gonna set
up a new request so options equals now
remember this is just like this one up
here up here where we have a URL and we
have if we want to do anything with the
JSON so I'm going to put URL and this is
going to be now if we go back over here
we can see that it's just going to be
free Co camp that org slash and then
it's the user name so let's copy that
and paste it in here freako camp org
slash and then this is where I'm going
to add a plus and user data we're gonna
be looping over this so I is the index
that we're looping through dot name and
what I am going to just change this just
to these back ticks that's what the best
practice is now so let's see now I'm not
actually going to do anything with the
JSON I'm gonna do something else it's
going to be it's going to be trans form
body now this is where we're gonna use
that cheerio that we brought in so
cheerio that load body we're gonna be
able to navigate this this HTML kind of
like using something like jQuery and now
we're going to make the actual request
so rp4 request promised pass in the
options and it's made dot then function
here's the results I'm gonna put into a
variable that's just a dollar sign kind
of inspired by jQuery just so we know
every time something's loaded I'm going
to do process st d out dot right and
then we'll know if a user is being
loaded so now one thing I also want to
check for is well if we go back over
here to this list of users I'm going to
try to find one trying to see if I could
remember basically some of these
don't have the same user name I'm free
coke amp so if I copy this user name
here and I put it again at the end of my
URL it says we couldn't find a page for
/john - free code camp so I want my
results to be able to know whether it's
actually getting data from the free coke
amp user page or not so the way I
figured out to do that was just to check
if there's a a so if I go into here and
if I inspect this you can see it's
landing - heading so I'm gonna see if
that exists so I'm going to do const FCC
account this is going to end up being a
boolean equals and then this is where we
can do a look for that tag each one dot
landing heading and then I'm going to
put dot length equals equals zero so if
the length is zero that means it doesn't
exist on the page but this will be true
if they do have an account and false if
they don't have an account with that
username we're gonna do a conjures test
this is to figure out how many
challenges they've passed and actually
the code for this I got right from the
article I made it pretty similar to how
how they got the number of challenges on
here so first I want to see if they have
an account so this is gonna be a ternary
operator do they have an account let me
scroll down here so if they do have an
account then we can find out how many
challenges they pass so we're going to
look for tbody TR and then do dot length
and if not we're just gonna do a string
we're going to set the challenges pass
to unknown we don't know how many
challenges that they passed maybe they
have a different username that they use
I'm phreak okay org so if we go back
over here
I'm going to go back to this page so if
I the reason why this works if I inspect
this you can see we have a TR let me go
back so it's T body TR so in the T body
and the TR so each TR is its own row on
here so basically we're just counting
the rows in that and the number of rows
is the number of challenges that the
person passed so when you're doing web
scraping you often have to go into the
code and try to figure out exactly what
you need to count for it to make sense
to get the actual data we could have
just gotten this number right here but
that number is not just that number
includes the challenges passed and they
could also get a higher number based on
helping people in the the chatroom but I
just want the number of challenges
passed so I want to count every line in
this row so it would include like if
these projects if I go to inspect this
you'll see this also has T body TR so
it's going to include the projects that
they pass to so it's gonna include
everything on here it doesn't include
the headings or anything so when it
counts every single line in this table
that will give you the the number here
and so again when your web scraping you
just have to look a lot the code to
figure out the best way to do it so
luckily this is not rendered with
JavaScript it's just we get a page that
has all that in there within the HTML so
that's why we're able to do this we got
the results but we want to push the
results to a table so let's set up the
table options up here because we're
gonna make a tape this table is just
going to appear in the console so I'm
gonna put let's see next I'm not going
to put it there I'm going to put right
down here so let table equals new table
and this is just from that CLI table
thing that we brought in here it needs
specific options we have the heading so
what's the heading of the table gonna be
like
and the first column is gonna be
username and then the second column so
me heart so if I do ctrl command space
that should bring up this if you're
using Mac so I'm going to put in a heart
there and then challenges so I just used
that emoji because of how many hearts
that they've received and now I also
have to make the column width so I'm
gonna put CEO l wi d th s widths and I
had already experimented with this and I
found that 15 5 10 are gonna be the good
column widths now let me go back over
here table dot push and then I'm going
to push on this information this array
so it's going to be user data and then I
for what index Ron dot name then user
data i dot likes received and challenges
passed so those are all the information
there for the different columns and then
I'm going to just increment that I and
then I'm going to put return next it's
going to keep running this function and
if I is less than user data dot length
it's going to do all this where it gets
the next users information and then
eventually I will it will run function
that next and I will not be less than
user dot length so we're not going to go
through this and return and run the
return next so this is a basically our
base case so our base case when I put
else print data so I'm going to call
this other function call we're just
gonna print the data that's collected so
let me go down here oh so we also have
to call this return next to begin with
so down here after the function next we
have to actually call that so I'm going
to put return
next to call that function so it's going
to start that so now we're actually
getting close to the end here we're
going to define our print data function
so I'm gonna put function print data
okay I'm gonna put console dot log we've
been printing things through the same
with a console dot standard out dot
right printing system of the same line
so we want to get something to the new
line so we're just going to do a console
dot log just something to put on the to
the new line and I'm just gonna use this
checkbox here and then I'm going to do
another console dot log and I'm going to
print table dot to string so that is
going to print out our whole table in
the console now I'm probably had some
kind of errors here I don't know I'm
going to actually try running this and
see if it works so I'm going to go over
to my console and I'm gonna just put
node index is so let's see
unexpected identifier let's see what I
did wrong there always need a comma at
the end of here okay now let's see what
happens let's see throw air cannot find
module request ok well this will miss
you NPM install request it looks like we
just need the module request ok now
let's try it again
so it did something you can see has the
word loading here but then the program
seemed to end right away it's like to
kind of figure out why that is so
somehow it oh oh ok I see what the
problem is I forgot to put the
parentheses here so it never called that
function correctly to start off going
into the function so now let's try it
okay unhandled it says a cheerio is not
defined so let's see what oh I spelled
cheerio wrong here so I'll save that and
go into Mike here again okay it's
actually the dots mean it's actually
doing these calls the request to the
website to get the data so this does
seem to be working as its wait till this
finishes and here's the table so let me
just scroll up here so you can see it
loaded all that we've got user name the
heart challenges you can see when it
puts in the emoji it kind of messes up
the spacing here that's okay though but
you can see here's the heart and you see
you see 8850 134 so if we you can kind
of if we go over to here you can see
it's getting that number
8850 134 and then the way to check that
these are right you can see this one has
has quincy as less so quincy Larson if
you go over here and put that in there
so the way a check is to go through and
count every row I'm not going to do it
I've done it before the check and it was
right I'm not gonna do in this video but
feel free to do that if you want to
check you can also go in count 291 but
that's a lot easier to just account the
smaller one just to make sure it's
calculating it correctly but you can see
you can see here too now we can have the
number of hearts on the forum with the
number of challenges passed on the
website and we can see how they're
related so you can kind of when you
actually look through this it doesn't
seem like there's a major correlation
like this person has only four hearts
but also he's passed four hundred and
three challenges stand with a lot of
these have passed a lot of challenges
but they don't have very many hearts and
really the person who has the fewest
challenges pay
quincy larson but he has one of the the
number three to four spot for number of
hearts and you can see some of these
there's actually quite a few unknowns
here I'd be interested to it just makes
me wonder hmmm I wonder do they have
these people actually use freako camped
out or or they're just participating on
the forum most likely they do use free
coke amped up the main site and just
have a different user name but maybe not
so that this web scraping is a great way
to combine information from two
different sites to get the exact
information you're looking for I'm sure
that some of you watching may have even
better ideas of how to do this so if you
figured out a better way to do some of
these things put your idea in the
comments to this video so everyone else
can can see that because I love to learn
new ways to do things and it'd be great
to see what other people are doing in
regards to web scraping and that's it
my name is beau Karns thanks for
watching don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good